[Musik]
der Westen schaut mit Besorgnis auf das
Bündnis zwischen China und Russland und
auf die beiden Männer an der Spitze die
das globale Machtgefüge neu sortieren
wollen aber wie einig sind sich Putin
und Ski was ist die Strategie Russlands
was will China und was setzt der
westendem entgegen und damit herzlich
willkommen zum internationalen
Frühschoppen heute mit diesen Gästen bei
uns ist Erik Kirschbaum er ist freier
Journalist unter anderem für die LA
Times
und bei uns ist Astrid Prange die
Oliviera sie ist Redakteurin in der
brasilianischen Redaktion der Deutschen
Welle
und Felix Lee ist bei uns er ist
Journalist unter anderem bei table Media
und herzlich willkommen Udo lischkis
ehemaliger ARD Studioleiter in Moskau
der Wettlauf Chinas Russlands und des
Westens um die Gunst afrikanischer
Staaten zeigt ja wie sehr die
Weltordnung in Bewegung geraten ist und
wir haben die Woche den Russland
afrika-gipfel erlebt und auch Putins
versucht den Eindruck von neuen
Machtverhältnissen auf der Welt
herzustellen und sich so als Wohltäter
Afrika zu präsentieren ist ihm das
gelungen
da habe ich große Zweifel es gab glaube
ich den den sympathischen Staatschef der
ja die den Krieg in der Ukraine halbwegs
befürwortet hat es gab aber auch viele
mahnende Stimmen ich glaube das hat
wenig zu tun mit sympathienten haben
keine Freunde sondern Interessen und das
geht glaube ich erst recht im Bereich
der afrikanischen Staaten da geht es
klar darum man möchte nicht sich ein
rein in die Gruppe der sanktionierende
Ländern hat Angst
dann wird habe ich ein Nachteil dazu
bekommen andere spekulieren auf
preiswerte Rohstoffe
es gab dadurch aus auch Kritik an der
Aufkündigung des getreideabkommens
teilweise wurde es als deutschstoß
glaube ich vom vom kenianischen
Präsidenten bezeichnet in den Rücken es
war ja auch nur die Hälfte der der
Staatschefs da natürlich mit dem letzten
Mal die Handelsbeziehungen in Russlands
zu afrikanischen Staaten sind auch eher
dürftig putin hatte ja in solchen beim
letzten Afrika Gipfel 40 Milliarden
versprochen es sind glaube ich 18 Uhr
geworden also da ist auch viel Schatten
aber Putin braucht natürlich jede
Gelegenheit um zu zeigen er ist nicht
isoliert seine festen Getreuen
Verbündeten sind ja durchaus
überschaubar das Nordkorea Syrien die
gerade Venezuela sind nicht viele
mehr darum sich als nicht isoliert zu
präsentieren oder auch die afrikanischen
Staaten tatsächlich in der Situation zu
bringen wo er durch Militärhilfe und
Weizen Lieferung sie sozusagen wirklich
ich auch ein bisschen erpresst oder auf
seiner Seite zieht ja natürlich
Wagner die etwa in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik ja sehr
erfolgreich versucht hat den Zugriff auf
Rohstoffvorkommen zu bekommen dahinter
steckt auch fast immer dann ein Kreis
rund um putinsgetreue
die da ihre Deals machen das war in
Syrien nicht anders da hat Wagner ja
auch versucht Zugriff auf Ölquellen zu
kriegen und dahinter stand das Team Tim
chengo in einem Putin vertraute es ist
ein buntes Geflecht aus geopolitischer
Bedeutung natürlich will Putin Rückhalt
auch im Rahmen der UN da haben wir auch
25 Staaten meines Wissens afrikanische
sich enthalten bei der letzten
Resolution aber natürlich sind doch ganz
massive ökonomische Interessen des Putin
Regimes denn all diesen Ländern versucht
den Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen insgesamt
hat man ja so das Gefühl dass gerade
wirklich sehr viel auf Staaten geblickt
wird wie auch Brasilien oder eben jetzt
über den Afrika Gipfel natürlich auf die
afrikanischen Staaten
ist das so dass diese Staaten bleiben
wir vielleicht noch für einen Moment
kurz bei Afrika wirklich noch bei Putin
sind zumindest die die auch angereist
sind
also ich würde sagen in Brasilien hat
man da ein bisschen größeren Abstand es
scheint so als ob eigentlich das Thema
für Brasilien nicht so wichtig ist aber
auf der zweiten Ebene sitzt Brasilien
oder saß Brasilien beim afrika-gipfel in
Petersburg St Petersburg am Tisch weil
die ehemalige Präsidentin Dema husseff
ist ja die Leiterin der new development
Bank also der bricks Bank und sie ist
also in einer ganz entscheidenden
Position sie ist da in diese Position
reingekommen auch auf Empfehlung von
Brasiliens Präsident Luna und
da geht's jetzt darum dass der Kredite
vergeben werden und das ist natürlich
interessant also Kredite hauptsächlich
natürlich
mit den Projekte in afrikanischen oder
auch lateinamerikanischen Ländern
realisiert werden und die gehören dann
zur neuen Seidenstraße oder sonstigen
großen Vorhaben auch von
russischer Seite natürlich Russland
verstärkt er seine Präsenz in auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent sehr
und deswegen würde ich sagen lass saß
Brasiliens Präsident mit am Tisch
indirekt und ist glaube ich auch sehr
gut informiert und man hört auch wenig
Kritik von ihm also direkt direkte
Kritik indirekte Kritik schon aber
wirklich direkte Kritik ist würde ich
sagen moderat das ist in der Tat gerade
genau der Unterschied Amerika natürlich
hat direkte Kritik im Vorfeld geäußert
und linken hat dazu aufgerufen wirklich
dass die afrikanischen Länder doch Putin
dazu bringen wirklich wieder in das
getreideabkommen reinzugehen jetzt wie
was gehört haben wurde dann seitens
Putin das gratis Getreide versprochen
reicht das um die afrikanische Länder zu
besänftigen oder ist das eine Situation
wo vielleicht sogar gerade der Westen
wieder in der Gunst steigen könnte aus
ihrer Sicht ja ich glaube ich mein Puten
attackiert der der Bombe der diese
schöne Haare finde so ein ein russische
Stadt sein sollte mit russische Kulturen
man die ganze Welt sieht
kaputten kaum Freunde hat Puten musste
eine Reise nach Südafrika absagen weil
er vielleicht verhaftet werden sollt der
hat wirklich wenig Freunde der sitzt da
alleine in Russland oder probiert was
auf die Beine zu kriegen aber es gelingt
ihm nicht diese diese Gipfel ist ein
Witz das zeigt wie wenig Freunde er hat
nicht wie viel Freunde das hat wie sie
haben gesagt das ist halb so viel wie
vor ein paar Jahren
Puten ist zunehmender Leine und diese
Thema heute spannendes China wie lange
noch Puten so unterstützenhaupt herzig
wie die das tun genau das ist jetzt die
Frage an Felix wie Peking war ja jetzt
sehr verärgert das Putin dieses Getreide
Abkommen aufgekündigt hat wie wirkt sich
das jetzt aber das Verhältnis aus ja
also klar China ist verärgert dass das
ist überhaupt bislang einen Getreide
Abkommen gegeben hatte das hatte
sicherlich auch in großen Maßen mit
China zu tun weil china ist der größte
Beziehung von diesem getreideabkommen
die Ukraine war eigentlich als Lieferant
als Alternative aus chinesischer sich
gedacht nicht mehr so abhängig von
us-getreide oder australischen Getreide
zu sein also Ukraine sollte das dritte
Standbein sein für die
Nahrungssicherheit in China und das hat
Putin mehr oder weniger dazu nicht
gemacht also das wird Auswirkungen haben
aber ich glaube das Putin dass diesen
Schritt jetzt gewagt hat zeigt aber auch
dass das Verhältnis zu Peking schon seit
einiger Zeit nicht mehr das Beste ist
anders als nur wie vor einem Jahr
beschworen worden diese große
Freundschaft sie sagen starten haben
keine Freundschaften china hat am
wenigstens Freunde also es war alles
sehr sehr praktisch aber man hatte das
mit Moskau und Putin erstmal nach außen
hin so gezeigt aber das scheint jetzt
überhaupt nicht mehr zu funktionieren
also dass man merkt ja auch dass die
Töne sich verschärft haben natürlich
nach außen versucht man
da immer noch irgendwie
Geschlossenheit zu zeigen aber China hat
ja die große Befürchtung dass
der Krieg sich ausweitet in Form sondern
auch von anderen Krisen in Zentralasien
das wäre dann vor der Haustür von China
zugleich
prigoshi
diese
der der der der versuchte
qdar quasi auf Moskau das hat natürlich
auch Peking wahnsinnig verunsichert weil
Peking fürchtet ja nicht mehr als dass
er ein unberechenbares Regime in Moskau
zum Markt kommt da ist den ja Putin
immer noch lieber als jemand von der
wagnergruppe womöglich und das war ja
natürlich ein Zeichen der Schwäche von
Moskau aus und das macht Peking
natürlich auch nervös aber könnte sogar
helfen im Ukraine Krieg wenn man jetzt
sozusagen etwas langfristiger drauf
blickt das China jetzt die Auswirkungen
auch sehr direkt spürt mit dem betreiben
ja das ist ja immer so ein bisschen
unser Wunschdenken also wenn es wenn
sich wenn die beiden sich nicht mehr so
alt sind dass das irgendwie dann eine
positive Wendung nimmt und womöglich
der Ukraine kriegt dann auch beendet
wird so funktioniert das leider auch in
Peking nicht also man geht da schon
immer sehr sehr taktisch von man das
heißt wenn man
verärgert über in Peking über Moskau ist
heißt es nicht automatisch das Peking
sich dann auf Seiten des Westens schlägt
so das wäre eine Illusion von unserer
Seite wenn wir das Denken also sich
gegen Putin auszusprechen wäre
vermutlich aus chinesischer Sicht dann
ja mein Gott gegen Putin aussprechen
dass es dann sich womöglich eine united
front gegen Putin das so aussehen würde
soweit wird es nicht kommen also Peking
nutzt das sehr taktisch das ganze und
wird sich
auch wenn Peking momentan verärgert sein
wird über Putin der Haupt Rivale Pekings
ist auch weiterhin die USA und der
Westen letztendlich und ähm also da wird
China auch weiterhin keine rühmliche
Rolle spielen um den Ukraine krieg jetzt
in irgendeiner Weise beizulegen gespielt
eine positive Rolle in dem Russland
keine Atomwaffen einsetzt Olaf Scholz
hat diese Versprechen von Ski bekommen
und ich glaube Jeans Einfluss auf Usern
moderat ist schon da und China hat ein
großer wirtschaftliches Problem und in
Europa ist der Ruf von China jetzt
gelitten durch diesen Krieg und die
direkt Investition in Schiene stark
abgebrochen eingebrochen ich glaube
china will auch nicht dass diese Krieg
lange gehen und China meiner kann ein
wichtiger wurde spielen moderat gegen
Russland zu wirken diese Krieg
vielleicht etwas kurzer machen also
sonst wäre
ich ja wir wissen ja beide nicht weil
beide Systeme sind dermaßen
intransparent das wird glaube ich nicht
wissen was da unter der Decke noch
gespielt wird also wir haben im
Vorgespräche ein bisschen über China
gesprochen ihnen geht es ja leider
offenbar so wie mir es ist richtig
schwer da rein zu gucken man denkt immer
an Winston Churchill der mal sagte in
Russland das ist so als wenn Bulldoggen
unterm Teppich kämpfen und erst wenn die
ersten Knochen rausfliegen weiß man wer
gewonnen hat dass das ist glaube ich war
bei beiden Systemen ähnlich ich glaube
auch das stärkste Bindeglied ist dieser
Anti Amerikanismus ist die USA als fein
das ist ein starkes Band danach kommt
nicht mehr viel danach ist Russland auch
für China nicht so interessant außer
eben als billige Tankstelle als billiger
Rohstoff Lieferant und das macht sehr
gezielt die dampfen ja bei dem Preisen
also Russland verkauft Rohstoffe
teilweise gerade noch zu
Entstehungskosten zu Produktionskosten
China nutzt die Schwäche Russlands und
drückt die ganz brutal im Preis aber
immer lächeln natürlich diplomatisch
immer garniert mit schönen Sätzen wie
eine
unverbrechliche Freundschaft und sowas
hört man dann gerne aber ich glaube
dahinter ist eiskalt das Gefühl da haben
wir jetzt einen anderen dass ich selber
schlecht durch diesen verrückten Krieg
und das werden wir nutzen um noch
preiswerter an Dich die Rohstoffe zu
kommen Ende der Durchsage
ich glaube das Thema also Stichwort
Anti-Amerikanismus ist ganz wichtig weil
eigentlich spielt sich ja der Konflikt
auch zwischen zwei verschiedenen Gruppen
oder Plattformen ab also wir haben
einmal die G7 Staaten und wir haben dann
die bricks wir haben natürlich auch noch
G20 aber in der Brick sind halt also
Brasilien Russland Indien China und
Südafrika und die sind 40 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung und da verfängt dieser
anti-amerikanische Diskurs ne da ist es
ganz klar das sind ist das ist wir
wollen raus aus der Bevormundung was uns
jetzt Washington diktiert das ist vorbei
das ist auch nicht mehr die Plattform wo
man globale Probleme lösen kann und
hinter diesen hinter diesen narrativ
kann man eben viele Menschen versammeln
auch in den Lateinamerikas ist so denn
da ist halt das Feindbild der USA
Präsident und das ist ja auch nicht ohne
Grund also ich sag nur mal Stichwort USA
und in Kuba was kein Mensch mehr
versteht aber auch andere natürlich die
ganzen die ganze Geschichte also
Unterstützung von Militär dieser Touren
Menschenrechtsverletzung die Programme
vom internationalen Weltwährungsfonds
Moment bleiben wir noch mal am besten
bei Putin und Chi weil wir sonst glaube
ich den ich wollte Zuschauer aufgreifen
absolut das war nur noch mal kurz von
Moment da bleiben weil abgesehen von
diesem Anti-Amerikanismus was ist es was
die beiden wirklich verbindet also wie
muss man sich das vorstellen wir haben
gehört Freundschaften gibt es nicht aber
was ist das zwischen den beiden ist es
wirklich so dass schon jetzt China den
Takt angeht oder ist das noch irgendwo
auf Augenhöhe wie muss man sich das
vorstellen also China ist ja bislang
gewissermaßen unterschied ihn der große
Profiteur dieses Krieges also
langjähriger Rivale Russland ist
plötzlich nur noch Juniorpartner in
quasi in einer gewissermaßen in einer
Abhängigkeit und von China gedrängt
worden das zweite ist es natürlich jetzt
auch
im Zuge des zunehmenden Konfliktes
zwischen China und den USA ein
praktisches Instrument dem besten jetzt
insgesamt eine
quasi
ein Klaps mitzugeben und das dritte ist
natürlich
profitiert auch die chinesische
Wirtschaft von den westlichen Sanktionen
gegen Russland also sie stoßen ja genau
in die Lücke die der die die westlichen
Unternehmen hinterlassen das mag jetzt
volkswirtschaftlich jetzt gerade auch
richtig chinesische Wirtschaft jetzt
nicht wahnsinnig viel sein bei Russland
letztendlich wirtschaftlich doch auch
keine so große Rolle spielt im
Verhältnis wie zum Beispiel Europa oder
die USA oder andere Weltregion aber die
Chinesen sind nach Russland gekommen um
zu bleiben also das bleibt gewissermaßen
was sie den Ping und Putin natürlich
auch charakterlich eint ist das
diktatorische gehabt also wir haben ja
China war vorher zwar auch schon eine
Diktatur eine ein Parteien Diktatur aber
uns unter hier hat sich hier noch mal
sehr stark verändert also auch wenn es
weiterhin diesen Emblem KP läuft hat es
unterschiedliche Ping letztendlich ein
ein Regimewechsel gegeben im Sinne von
vorher war es eine kollektivführung die
regelmäßig alle zehn Jahre dann auch
gewechselt hat und so weiter hier den
Ping ist zudem ist zu einem Diktator
aufgestiegen also er hat sich dieser
kollektivführung mehr oder weniger
entledigt er hat er bleibt jetzt oder
kann jetzt
lebenslang
Machthaber bleiben und
entscheidet inzwischen auch viel viel
mehr alleine auch Fehlentscheidung
gehört natürlich dann ist dann natürlich
auch viel anfälliger weil er eben als
alleiniger Herrscher alles ist bestimmt
und dann eint genau damit
auch passiert genau damit sucht er sich
natürlich äh sucht dann mit in Form von
jemandem wenn es dann den großen
Nachbarn Russland gibt wo wo genau so
beherrscht wird ist das natürlich für
sie gewissermaßen auch eine Legitimation
ja dann kann ich dann ja in China auch
so herrschen aber gleichzeitig natürlich
auch eine enorme Gefahr sollte in einem
der Länder ist sozusagen so sein dass
die ja es ist ein Putsch gibt oder das
ist ein Aufbegehren gibt
möglicherweise der andere auch weil es
halt einfach so vergleichbar ist oder
wie haben Sie es empfunden jetzt gerade
auch nach dem Aufstand mit den
naja das hat Putin massiv geschwächt
sagen auch die meisten russischen
Beobachter bei diese Anmutung einer
funktionierenden machtvertikale der
völligen Kontrolle ist natürlich stark
gestört
wir wissen alle nicht wie es weitergeht
also Wissen über die Rede durchlesen die
ihr einen Tag nach Beginn dieses Protes
gehalten hat aber von Verrat die Rede
sie werden brutal abgestraft und jetzt
erleben wir Herrn prägogi in den Söldner
Chef schon wieder auf dem afrika-gipfel
im petersburg unmittelbarer Nähe
pooldienst ja also da hat er auch eine
Kröte geschluckt es ist schwer da rein
zu gucken aber was ich noch sagen wollte
ist natürlich ist China für Putin
extremst wichtig allein für die Anmutung
ich bin nicht alleine auf dieser Welt er
ist ja doch inzwischen weitgehend
isoliert wenn sie mal diesen genannten
Länder Nordkorea weglassen z.B was
Erdogan gemacht hat war ja auch nur
feige ja der hat ja nach der Wahl ein
ziemlich geehrtwendung hingelegt hat
also auf Kämpfe ukrainische Kämpfer
freigelassen entgegen das Abkommens hat
jetzt den Patrick Schwedens zur NATO
schon mal im Vorfeld zugestimmt das sind
ja Ohrfeigen für Putin und Putin hat
sehr milt reagiert was ich gar nicht
leisten kann das Verhältnis zur Türkei
zu beschädigen er hat nicht mehr viele
mit denen er noch auf Augenhöhe
verhandeln kann ja er hat weil es
wichtig viele als Moderator auch der
Konflikte kurz um das ist teilweise
glaube ich der Erkenntnis geschuldet
dass er nicht ganz im Hemd da stehen
möchte ja und da muss er die Kröten
schlucken ich habe gelesen dass er beim
letzten Treffen mit HI offenbar nach dem
Gespräch dann auf irgendeiner Gäste
Tribüne platziert wurde was China
beobachteten als eine wirkliche
Demütigung empfunden haben ich weiß ob
das stimmt aber das sind so kleine
subtile
in China glaube ich sehr wahrgenommene
Manöver mit denen die Zeit pass mal auf
du bist meine Kleine Rohstoff der
verwandt aber jetzt wird ja gar nicht
ein dass wir hier auf augenhöre wenn ist
das richtig beobachtet ja also definitiv
also genau solche Signale sind in für
die kappieführung in China traditionell
immer wichtig und
china hat sie ja lange Zeit gegen
Europäern die Russen mit eingeschlossen
immer
minderwertig gefühlt und zumindest jetzt
den großen Nachbarn Russland jetzt quasi
untertan gemacht zu haben das wird als
eine große Genugtuung in Peking
empfunden also solche solche Signale
solche symbolischen Bilder die werden da
sehr sehr
groß aufgegriffen in China ja das in
Amerika so wahrgenommen also wird da
wirklich so
hingeblickt wie wir das jetzt gerade
gehört haben oder konzentriert man sich
in den USA doch sowieso schon immer die
ganze Zeit stärker allein auf China als
Rivalen ja auf jeden Fall beiden seitdem
angekommen ist und Trump davor hat China
aus der große Gefahren gesehen und ähm
Europa Ukraine war wirklich nicht mehr
ganz so wichtig ist im Krieg aber die
wurde auch kein Europa immer geweint von
Deutschland geweint nicht so abhängig
sein von
diese Warnungen sind
ignoriert mehr oder weniger und dann
jetzt haben wir den Preis dafür und ich
hoffe und ich glaube dass Deutschland
jetzt mit dieser neue Strategie für
China wach geworden ist und sieht das
China auch eingefallen ist und
Deutschland ändert sich nicht so stark
wie die Außenministerin haben wollte
aber immerhin doch in einer in einer
Richtung das ist vielleicht ein Thema
kann ich muss das vereint China in
Russland aber wenn Europa mit den USA in
der gleiche Richtung sieht dann ist es
ein Wucht und dann dann ist er sein sehr
wichtiges Signal Schiene gegenüber das
ist nicht nur die USA die die Sachen
machen mit Chips verbieten und solche
Dinge das ist ohne Receiver die meiner
Kamera gar keine gar keine Frage aber es
ist wichtig wenn Europa auch in diese
gleiche Richtung sieht die gleiche Werte
wie die USA erwähnt und und China nicht
nur aus einem Absatzmarkt für deutsche
Autos sieht das in der Tat ja wirklich
jetzt viel passiert mit der eigenen
China Strategie die jetzt viel von die
risking spricht nicht in die kapling
also nicht ein komplettes abkoppeln aber
eben so dass man eine ganz groß darauf
achtet sich nicht zu abhängig zu machen
und vor allen Dingen bei
Schlüsseltechnologien ja wirklich eine
viel größere Vorsicht an den Tag zu
legen gibt es genau diese Art von
Diskussionen eigentlich in Brasilien
auch oder wie blickt man da auf dem
Partner China nee diese Art von Debatte
gibt es im Brasilien nicht also China
ist Brasiliens größte Handelspartner
also einfach nur damit man mal so eine
Idee hat ja also das sind
87 Milliarden Dollar die Brasilien nach
China exportiert nach Russland
exportiert Brasilien 1,5 Milliarden also
das zeigt schon die Dimension china ist
für Brasilien wichtig und umgekehrt
natürlich genauso weil es ist ein
Rohstofflieferant rasieren liefert alles
was China braucht Eisenerze so ja ne und
ähm
natürlich ist es auch für die Regierung
entscheidend dass sie dieses Verhältnis
mit Peking dass das gut läuft das ist
pragmatisch ist und da wollte ich eben
auch noch mal einhaken ich glaube auch
nicht also diese Isolierung macht glaube
ich Bündnis oder Plattform wie die Brix
umso wichtiger weil dort gibt es eben
diesen direkten Draht zwischen den fünf
Ländern und eben auch damit zu Putin und
Brasilien ist eben ein Land was mit
allen spricht es gibt also es hat eine
ganz klare Demokratie es ist Mitglied im
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof das ist
zum Beispiel bei Indien der größten
Demokratie der Welt ja nicht der Fall
das heißt es gibt eben auch eine Werte
Beziehung und ja und jetzt gab es dieses
Beispiel Putin fährt nicht nach
Südafrika so weil es gab also es gab
dann eben diese Kanäle und diese diese
Debatten aber natürlich kommt dann eben
der Außenminister hallervorf und äh
natürlich wird innerhalb dieser Gruppe
debattiert und natürlich ist es jetzt
auch für die EU oder die USA
wichtig dann vielleicht über Brasilien
zu gehen oder über Südafrika um wiederum
dann den Draht zu bekommen weil es ist
ganz klar Brasilien wird wird auf China
da wird also wird es auf keinen Fall
eine Verschlechterung wünschen und zu
Russland klar Russland ist natürlich
jetzt
billiger Treibstoff also zwei Drittel
des Diesels den Brasilien Ex also
importiert kommt zurzeit aus Russland
das war vorher nicht der Fall das
bedeutet wiederum billiger Treibstoff in
Brasilien werden fast alle waren über
LKW transportiert es gibt ja fast kein
Schienennetz das bedeutet günstiger
Transportkosten günstigere
Lebensmittelpreise weniger Inflation das
ist für Lula perfekt das ist nur ganz
wichtig das bedeutet für den Alltag der
Menschen dass sie das ist dass die
Preise nicht mehr steigen und die Preise
steigen sowieso gerade wegen des Ukraine
Kriegs und wegen der ganzen
Verwicklungen und wenn wir jetzt da
einen Faktor haben wo wo vielleicht
Entlastung ist auch wenn es also völlig
verdreht ist und absolut nicht korrekt
aber für die Leute die jeden Tag
wirklich gucken müssen wie sie über klar
kommen ist das ein Faktor wenn die
Transportkosten nicht so hoch sind ich
glaube auch die bricks starten also die
großen Schwellenländer Brasilien in
Russland Indien China Südafrika ich
glaube das ist auch wahrscheinlich die
geopolitisch größte Cäsur die wir
momentan erleben wir haben die Jahre
lang haben wir diese bricks blechelt
weil was haben diese Länder denn gemein
die haben sich
könnten sich eigentlich auch gar nicht
aber was wir jetzt halt erleben ist
wahrscheinlich mögen die sich auch
weiterhin nicht und äh sind ja auch
völlig unterschiedliche Systeme aber all
was diese Staaten jetzt erkannt haben
ist dass sie da jetzt genau solche
Bündnisse solche
Kooperation quasi strategisch nutzen
nicht unbedingt dass sie jetzt große
Freunde sind aber dass sie plötzlich
merken oh es gibt eine Alternative zu
dem bislang dominanten Westen unter der
Führung der USA und jetzt gibt es China
der immer aushelfen kann und man geht da
sehr sehr taktisch vor und das er wir
wundern uns ja warum dann plötzlich
Südafrika dann auch nicht mit in dem
Chor des Westens mit sinkt oder auch
Brasilien und so weiter da merkt man
dass im Grunde auch jetzt auch nicht nur
die brig-staaten selber sondern im
Grunde alle Länder des globalen Südens
jetzt ganz taktisch schauen je nach
Situation wie man damit stimmt
Hauptsache ist nutzt einem selbst und
das ist glaube ich eine Zäsur auf die
wir im Westen noch nicht vorbereitet
sind und das wahrscheinlich so die
Geopolitik der nächsten Jahrzehnte
bestimmen sind mit der alte Spruch ist
die economy stupid also ich glaube die
Wirtschaftskraft die haben wir teilweise
aus den Augen verloren auch ich habe
gerade Zahlen gelesen dass die
brix-staaten offenbar ja sich
hochgeboschelt haben im weltweiten
Sozialprodukt von zehn auf über 31
Prozent während die G7 Staaten von 50
auf 30 zurückmarschiert sind also da
verschiebt sich wahnsinnig viel und ich
glaube der der ehemalige reiche Westen
tut sich immer noch ein bisschen schwer
damit das zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und
auch ein bisschen sage ich mal mit mehr
Respekt auf solche Länder zuzugehen und
da sitzt tief ich glaube das sind bis
hin zu kolonialen Erfahrungen mit dem
arroganten Industrieländern des Westens
das kriegen wir teilweise jetzt heute
noch um die Ohren
also das sind 40 Prozent der
Weltbevölkerung und 25 Prozent der
weltweiten Wirtschaftsleistungen bei den
kriegsstaaten und das Interessante ist
ja es gibt eine Liste von ungefähr 20
Ländern die auch in die Brix hinein
wollen und jetzt gibt es eine große
Debatte in dem Club ja Moment wir sind
ja eigentlich nur fünf Staaten wir
wollen eigentlich auch gar nicht dass es
diese beitrittsdebatte jetzt hier Fahrt
aufnimmt aber was passiert dann dann
werden die alle Mitglied werden Bank das
ist sozusagen der Vorhof und da gehen
die alle rein und das wird natürlich
jetzt in Südafrika im August darüber
wird gesprochen also Ägypten möchte rein
ganz viele andere lernen möchten rein
weil sie eben merken dass ihre Damen
Algerien die möchten es gibt andere
Möglichkeiten wir brauchen uns nicht der
Weltbank
Plattform unterzuwerfen um an Kredite zu
kommen und das brauchen wir brauchen
Expansionen und
ja und wir können da es ist wertefrei
also niemand fragt mich wie gesagt ob
ich jetzt
im strafgerichtsberuf Mitglied bin oder
nicht und das sind diese Punkte die eine
gewisse Attraktivität aufzumachen wobei
ja gleichzeitig trotzdem sie haben es
schon erwähnt Putin nicht anreisen kann
zu diesem Gipfel in vier Wochen weil er
ja in der Tat mit internationalem
Haftbefehl natürlich auch dann nicht
einreisen könnte der Punkt ist aber
interessant weil es geht ja auch darum
sich unabhängiger von dem Dollar zu
machen
wie blicken die USA da drauf das ist ja
schon einfach hier aufgrund der
Bevölkerungsanzahl natürlich wirklich
geht ja tatsächlich um wirtschaftliche
Interessen ja keine Wohnung nicht die
Türen das allerdings nutzen muss aber
sie haben gesagt dass die Wirtschaft der
alte Länder nicht mehr so wichtig ist
aber USA in China zusammen haben 40% der
Welt Inlandsprodukt das sind dynamische
Wirtschaft in diesem total abhängig
aneinander das ist auch ein
friedensgarant und die Amerikaner wollen
mit linkin will unbedingt mit China
wieder ins Gespräch kommen ein Boden so
reichen war die Wirtschaft von beiden
Länder sind so wahnsinnig voneinander
abhängig ob mit Taiwan und so deswegen
es gibt überhaupt keine Interesse an
einem Krieg von USA total Taiwan Seite
und und diese dynamische große
Wirtschaft ja leider sind die beiden die
größte zwei Wirtschaften der Welt
zweiter groß die militäre der Welt auch
aber das sind die Fakten und und die
können natürlich jetzt wunderbar
ausgespielt werden von sage ich mal
Brasilien oder afrikanischen Staaten
weil in der Tat das geopolitische
Interesse gerade so groß ist und das
kann man natürlich auch nutzen was kann
denn der Westen tun ja wenn der besten
zusammen bleibt
gesehen in Europa wie wunderbar Europa
zusammengeblieben ist in diesem Krieg
gegen ähm Russland Krieg gegen Ukraine
das hat man wunderbar gesehen ich habe
das noch nie erlebt dass so einig war
und in Europa und die USA zusammen
ähnliche Politik gegenüber China haben
dann ist es dann ist die halbe Miete
aber wir haben einen Namen glaube ich
vergessen zu erwähnen und er heißt
Donald Trump und ich lese jetzt häufiger
Artikel die mich ein bisschen schlechter
schlafen lassen weil es nicht mehr
völlig ausgeschlossen wird dass er der
Spitzenkandidat der Republikaner wird
bereitet Offenbach auch schon vieles vor
ich weiß dass das jeder die Chancen
Trumps nicht so hoch einschätzen aber
das Risiko ausschließen glaube ich
können wir alle nicht ja und das wäre
dann eine ganz ganz neue Baustelle alles
spekulieren aber momentan gibt es ein
Präsident der heißt Joe Biden und die
Geschichte hat uns gezeigt der Abend hat
fast immer gewonnen seitdem
ist aber noch nie so alt wie wie bei
beiden ja aber schon ist auch fast so
alt die beiden und und dynamischer Junge
aus manchmal
deswegen ich weiß von beiden ist sein
Auto ein Problem für manche Leute aber
für viele demokratische Bilder glaube
ich ist kein Problem die sehen das
entscheiden hat die beste Chance zu
gewinnen und
Olaf Schulz hat auch gesagt dass beiden
ist sehr fit mental und mag seine Sachen
ganz gut aber was passiert wir haben ja
eigentlich jetzt nur noch roundabout 12
Monate bis der Wahlkampf so richtig in
Fahrt sein wird in Amerika und was
passiert dann mit den Themen Ukraine
oder auch Taiwan können wir vielleicht
später noch zu wie groß ist der Rückhalt
der Amerikaner zu sagen ja da gehen
wirklich alle diese Milliardenbeträge
hin erstens ist Außenpolitik in den USA
ein nur für Politik das hat überhaupt
kaum ein Wahl überhaupt beeinflussen
zweitens ist die Demokraten und
Republikaner und hat nicht einig Schiene
gegenüber und auch bisher Russland
gegenüber das ist äh eine sind zwei
wenige Gebiete wo die hier amerikanische
Parteien ziemlich einig sind dass man
muss stark stärker gegen Schiene zeigen
und auch stärker gegen Russland
nicht ganz so stark ja Trump ist sagt
manchmal Dinge verschiedene Tage Dinge
Sachen was wir am Tag davor nicht gesagt
hat aber ich glaube wir haben ein
President und es ist Musik hier so
spekulieren während zwei Jahren
Präsident sein wird wir gucken auf die
Geschichte der abends Inhaber hat was
immer gewonnen ich stimme ja in
vollkommen zu dass die wirtschaftliche
Abhängigkeit USA China gegenseitig sehr
sehr groß ist aber ich glaube nicht dass
du trotz dass ich das auch in den
nächsten Zeit verschieben wird und zwar
auch selbst wenn du bei einem Präsident
bleiben will weil das ja genau der Punkt
ist wo sich beide Seiten in den USA ja
auch einig sind die große Rivalität die
große Bedrohung durch China auch die
Rivalität die technologische Bedrohung
die von China droht und ich glaube
insofern werden wir schon auch in den
nächsten Jahren auch in Deutschland auch
mit der China Strategie vielleicht keine
Entkopplung von China erleben weil ich
glaube allen rational denkenden Menschen
klar ist dass man Welt Musik ohne China
nicht mehr gestalten kann also man
braucht China in den ganz wesentlichen
Fragen in der Klimapolitik aber auch in
vielen geopolitischen und
wirtschaftspolitischen Aspekten aber
nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich wird es ein
gewissermaßen ein
ja eine ein Auseinanderdriften geben und
ich meine was wir momentan erleben ist
ja letztendlich so ein bisschen wofür
die Europäer sich eigentlich
letztendlich offiziell immer noch
einsetzen eine multipolare Weltordnung
ich glaube wir haben es nur noch auch in
den akademischen Debatten noch nicht
verinnerlicht was das heißt dass die
werden nämlich damit unglaublich noch
mal komplizierter werden wird und
und wir deswegen
jetzt auch auf sehr sehr unsichere
Zeiten zusteuern werden geopolitisch da
hat China natürlich auch keine Antworten
darauf also china will einerseits die
Dominanz der Amerikaner brechen
andererseits profitierten sie ja bislang
auch immer noch gewissermaßen davon
nicht an erster Stelle zu stehen sondern
wenn es mal mit der Weltwirtschaft nicht
ganz so gut läuft dann auch immer die
Schuld in Amerikaner zuzuschieben weil
sie ja immer noch die größten sind aber
die Richtung ist schon klar dass China
äh diese Dominanz brechen will
der Jörn holt auf zwar nicht so schnell
wie befürchtet das hat aber auch damit
zu tun weil China die Kontrolle über die
eigene Währung nicht verlieren will und
das ist das Problem der
Internationalisierung aber da wird viel
ausprobiert von chinesischer Seite aus
und viele Länder sehen darin eine Chance
ja eben nicht mehr diese Dollar
Abhängigkeit zu haben und plötzlich zu
sehen oder gibt es vielleicht eine
zweite Währung und die heißt auch leider
nicht der Euro da würde ich gerne noch
mal reingehen weil das war ja genau eine
Forderung von der Dema Russe also von
der brix-bankchefin dass sie gesagt hat
die Geschäfte innerhalb der
brix-staaten und auch zum Beispiel im
Austausch Russland afrikanische Staaten
China afrikanische Staaten dass die in
lokalen Währung stattfinden sollen und
das auch der Johann als Währung mir an
Gewicht gewinnen soll also alles in
dieser Linie eben die Dominanz des
Dollars einzuschränken meine Frage wäre
jetzt wie also was würde das dann
bedeuten eigentlich wenn der Dollar die
Kontrolle verliert ist das realistisch
und wenn ja ähm
was bedeutet das dann eigentlich also
eine multipolare Welt
guckt der stark darauf wie stark sind
die einzelnen Pole und einen starker
Pool sollte eigentlich die Europäische
Union sein aber das erkennen wir leider
nicht das ist das Problem auch wenn die
chancentrums gering sind das hoffe ich
auch so
gibt es aber diese Möglichkeit dass
dieser Mann zurückkehrt mit all den
dieser strösen Auswirkungen die wir klar
absehen können etwa im Bereich der NATO
ich kann nicht erkennen dass die
Europäer auch nur ansatzweise
vernünftige Schritte zeigen hin zu einer
gemeinsamen europäischen
verteidigungs-
ich sehe dagegen dass unsere alten
klassischen Industrien schwer auf dem
Abstieg sind Auto bei den Deutschen etwa
ich sehe auch dass wir bei
Zukunftstechnologien hoffnungslos
hinterher roppeln das heißt in dieser
multipolaren neuen Welt sind die
Europäer ein erschreckend kleiner Pool
und was bedeutet
Niger genau da manifestiert es sich ja
dass das eigentlich für die Franzosen
vor allem sehr wichtige geostrategische
das ganze Regierung strategische
Bedeutung hat einfach auch weil
Frankreich ja aus dem Land das Uran
bekommt für die Atomkraftwerke
wie stark ist da die europäische
Position überhaupt noch in Ländern wie
jetzt die Liga wohnten die EU ja klar
gesagt hat ne das wird jetzt nicht
akzeptiert und die Hilfen sollen
gestrichen werden verfängt das noch oder
also ich meine wenn es nach den Menschen
geht die Afrikaner wollen würden immer
noch Europa bevorzugen als nach China
oder nach Russland zu gehen also ich
meine das insofern das ist immer noch in
Hoffnung schon mal dass du dir
europäische Gedanken noch nicht komplett
verschwunden ist auf der Welt also das
hat sogar ich würde sogar sagen ganz
erhebliches Gewicht aber ja klar also
aber nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir halt ähm
all diese Länder liegen werden sich
nicht mehr festlegen sie werden jetzt
nicht mehr sagen okay wir sind jetzt pro
westlich oder wir sind jetzt
anti-westlich sehr pro Russland oder so
sondern sie werden ganz ganz geschickt
schauen irgendwie welchen Nutzen man
jeweils dabei bezieht und da ist China
immer ein sehr attraktiv eine sehr
attraktive Alternative weil im
Unterschied zum Westen China überhaupt
keine politische moralischen Bedingungen
setzt sondern es wirklich tatsächlich in
dem Sinne mal wirklich auf Augenhöhe
geht es geht um Geschäfte machen und
und das kann jeder dieser Staaten dann
für sich entscheiden macht man das
natürlich ist China dann auch dominant
und hat dann natürlich auch sehr viel
wirtschaftliche Macht und Kraft aber das
ist trotzdem eine andere Ebene als ich
sage jetzt mal der Westen der dann immer
auch ein Stück weit hat er ja auch nicht
immer konsequent durchgehalten aber ein
Stück weit auch immer ein bisschen mit
dem moralischen Zeigefinger kommt der
entfällt jetzt und diese multipolare
Weltordnung so schön das klingt ich
glaube das ist jetzt aber auch wirklich
eine Hausaufgabe all das Think Tanks
sich jetzt mal Gedanken zu machen wie
denn eine regelbasierte multipolare
Weltordnung aussehen kann bei was
momentan droht diese multipolare
Weltordnung das von plötzlich dann
irgendwann nur noch das rechte Stärkeren
gilt und das ist natürlich das wird für
wahnsinnig viel Unsicherheit auf der
ganzen Welt sorgen und ähm und ich
glaube das ist umso wichtiger dass ich
jetzt ganz ganz intensiv Gedanken machen
auch für eine regelbasierte multipolare
Weltordnung zu werden die überhaupt mal
zu definieren ich glaube die ist auch in
hierzulande noch nicht klar definiert
also das ist sicherlich der erste
Schritt und klar die Umsetzung das wird
auch nochmal sehr sehr schwierig das
Recht des Stärkeren das zeigt sich ja
jetzt auch so ein bisschen in so
gegenseitigen Machtdemonstrationen wenn
die USA jetzt Militärgüter an Taiwan
liefern mit der Begründung man wolle
nicht den gleichen Fehler machen wie bei
der Ukraine und erst im Nachhinein
sozusagen reagieren sondern
schon jetzt Militärgüter zu liefern ist
das aus ihrer Sicht wichtiger und
richtiger Schritt oder doch eine
Provokationen nicht Provinz
alle jungen wenn es vom Kriege kommt
aber die USA hat lange unterstützt diese
Freiheit genau wie die Freiheit West
Berlin verteidigt hat ich glaube keine
in Deutschland hat sich in Frage
gestellt warum haben die mir keine
wespen sind verteidigt das auch keine
Provokation gegenüber aus Berlin und
Maske auch einfach diese diese diese
Idee Freiheit muss man unterstützen und
ich glaube diese Ukraine Krieg die Welt
hat viel gelernt die haben gelernt dass
die russische Militär ist doch nicht so
stark wie wir gedacht haben wir haben
auch gelernt dass es lohnt sich nicht
eine starke militäre zu nutzen das kann
vielleicht schief gehen ein starker
Militär ist nicht unbedingt ein Garant
für einen Erfolg im schlagfelder das
haben die Chinesen sicherlich auch
studiert und und gelernt und man kann
auch viel verlieren putens putens
Regimes sicher zu sein vor zwei Jahren
jetzt wer weiß wie lange Puten noch da
bleibt er hat alles gespielt er verliert
alles zu verlieren und das ist ein
weinendes Beispiel für verschiedene
denke ich auch ist das so dass er droht
alles zu verlieren oder wartet er
schlichtweg ab bis ich beispielsweise in
Amerika die Machtverhältnisse verändern
na klar das System ist hat deutliche
Risse bekommen ich bin sicher das Putin
nicht gut schläft zurzeit weil er noch
nicht einmal weiß welche Teile seiner
Sicherheitsstrukturen stehen loyal zu
mir da gab es ja irre witzige Begegnung
auch pregorian trifft einen Vize
verteilungsminister ein Vize-Chef des
Auslandsgeheimdienstes eher kumpelhaft
sagen die du kannst scheuburg haben über
das kolportiert kurz um es war ja ein
Phänomen dass da ein paar Männer auf
Moskau marschieren 13 Piloten abschießen
können russische und dass der Kerl
trotzdem jetzt wieder in Petersburg um
mal steht auf dem Afrika Gipfel also all
das zeigt natürlich enorme
Frakturen oder oder Risse in diesem
putinsystem wir gucken aber nicht genau
rein wir wissen nicht wie tief sind die
und wann geht's auf ja aber dass das
kein stabiles System ist ist völlig klar
es gab vor einiger Zeit ein paar Jahre
ist ja ein Artikel in der New York Times
Tier ist ist Putin Ace Agent das man
hieronischer
einfach weil er so systematisch
ökonomischen Grundlagen seines eigenen
Landes beschädigt durch die völlige
Rechtsfreiheit durch diese diese
fassungslose Bereicherung seiner Eliten
und so weiter
Russland ist ein anscheinend Riese sage
ich gerne das ist ein hohler Körper da
ist ein leuchtendes Moskau das
Disneyland Russlands und der Rest ist
ein Armenhaus mit unvorstellbarer
kaputten Strukturen und eine alles
zerfressenden auch die Armee
zerfressenden Korruption ja und das ist
eine Frage der Zeit und natürlich tut
den hat den Wecker auf den nächsten
November gestellt auf die US-Wahl
natürlich ist die Hoffnung dass die
unrecht haben und dass ein einer Trump
z.B wieder dass das Rennen macht und
damit die Ukraine ihren wichtigsten
Unterstützer verliert das ist gut ins
Kalkül und der stellt gerade alle
Weichen in diese Richtung die dumme hat
noch einen Tag vor Sommerpause neue
Gesetze verabschiedet die das
einbuchungsalter erhöht haben auf 30 und
viele andere Mechanismen mit denen der
eine ständige erweiterte Mobilisierung
vollziehen kann
die Summen die hier rein steckt ja man
schätzt dass er mit der all den
Konversationen bis zu 20 Milliarden also
zehn Prozent der Staatsausgaben im
letzten Jahr in diesem Krieg geballert
hat
Russen kriegen viel viel Geld wenn sie
kämpfen ja bis zum neunfachen des
Durchschnittslohns und wenn sie sterben
das hat eine ausgerechnet gerade mal ein
Experte muss man bis zu 150.000
$, das ist unfassbar das entspricht 31
Jahresgehalt dann im Durchschnitt also
er investiert wahnsinnig viel Geld um
diesen Krieg irgendwie am Laufen zu
halten und es sind keinster Weise
absehbar dass er vor hat den denn
irgendwie ab zu beenden oder zu
verhandeln gab welche Vorstellung der
kriegt seine Macht und er hält ihn an
der Macht dennoch gibt es die Bemühungen
seitens Brasilien Seiten China wie auch
immer man die zu bewerten hat in vier
Wochen findet dieser brix-gipfel statt
halten Sie es für realistisch dass man
auf diesen Gipfel auch wenn es nur
kleine Schritte sind irgendwie auf Putin
einwirken wird können oder teilen Sie
die Ansicht von Handys dass das
eigentlich
utopisch ist
ich glaube man kann Russland nicht
ignorieren man kann auch nicht sagen es
geht nicht also ich glaube dass
es hat mir jetzt ja auch gesehen auf dem
afrika-gipfel es gab ja wirklich von
allen Seiten her die bitte bitte lass
das Getreide Abkommen wieder auflegen ne
wir müssen das Verändern der Druck ist
einfach da von der Straße die Leute
haben kein Geld für teure sag ich mal
haben kein Spielraum für erhöhte
Nahrungsmittelpreise und lebenspreise
dieser Druck den verspüren natürlich
auch viele Staatschefs in auf dem
afrikanischen Kontinent und auch sonst
in der Welt das heißt ich glaube da wird
es sicherlich darum gehen wie können wir
diese Situation entspannen es gab ja
auch eine afrikanische Delegation die
versucht hat friedensverhandlung zu
führen die Waren in Kiel und in Moskau
vielen ja dann die Bomben das ist
natürlich auch eine Antwort wie man das
sehen kann
Lula hat es auch probiert weil er eben
diesen neutralen Zugang hat aber
er hat auch gezeigt ihm dass er für
diesen lateinamerikanischen narrativ der
Linken eben ist sozusagen wo wo Russland
ein Bonus hat weil es anti-amerikanisch
ist so und dann schickt man beiden so
erstmal die Schuld zu da war ja klar
also da hat er sich ein bisschen
verbrannt als er gesagt hat keiner will
den Krieg beenden die Ukraine will den
Krieg nicht beenden und Russland will
den Krieg auch nicht beenden da war
natürlich erstmal ein großer aufstand
und mittlerweile ist er ja etwas
zurückgerudert und hat gesagt ja also
ich muss jetzt erstmal den Krieg in
meinem eigenen Land irgendwie
in den Griff bekommen also der Krieg
gegen Hunger und Arbeitslosigkeit und
ich werde mich jetzt da etwas raushalten
aber das natürlich das alle
Friedensinitiativen hat er auch mehrfach
angekündigt dass er da Interesse hat
jetzt hat er Saudi Arabien eine
Initiative vorgelegt ähm also ich glaube
das wird immer wieder weiter neue
Initiativen geben weil es einfach die
Welt sich so nicht leisten kann in
dieser Unsicherheit zu bleiben mit und
diese Unsicherheit führt ebenso ja zu
Preissteigerung auf allen Ebenen und
auch zu politischen umweltbarkeiten die
für alle Nachteile Bergen das heißt ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
irgendjemand dann sagt selbst mit Syrien
haben wir noch nicht aufgehört so
ungefähr da gibt es wo wir dachten das
ist schon vielleicht
überhaupt nicht mehr sinnvoll nein es
wird natürlich wird es weitergehen und
es wird immer wieder Friedensangebote
geben und es geht immer wieder
Möglichkeiten geben zu sagen
zumindestens weniger schlecht als jetzt
also eine minimale Verbesserung ist
besser als keine Verbesserung das glaube
ich schon völlig egal er hat ein ganz
zentrales Motiv das ist er möchte an der
Macht bleiben weil er sonst
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mehr allzu
lange gesund bleibt das ist ein
Hauptmotiv und dazu braucht er diesen
Krieg wie soll das denn aussehen stellt
sich nun mal vor das unsere netten
Pazifisten erfolgreich dafür werden es
gibt Gespräche die Ukraine tritt sogar
vielleicht Gebiete ab dann muss Putin
seinem Volk erklären warum er diesen
unfassbar blutigen Krieg geführt hat für
was ja für ein zwei Gebiete im dornbas
und ein Teil von SAP unmöglich also es
wird auch nicht passieren weil die
Ukraine kennen Land preisgeben werden
das ist völlig klar aber nein gar nicht
einlenken geht gar nicht und noch mal
einen Satz zum getreideabkommen das geht
ja nicht darum dass er da gehobene
Staatsinteressen Russlands im Auge hat
es geht auch teilweise ganz knallhart
darum einen großen Konkurrenten auf dem
Getreidemarkt auszuschalten nämlich die
Ukraine einfach weil die Putin Elite
dominiert den russischen Getreide
Handeln der Sohn von pattro Chef ist
einer der großen Agrar Barone ja da geht
es wirklich um ganz eiskalte Interessen
Geld verdienen für die ihm loyal
umgebenden originchen das ist der Punkt
danke erstmal bis hierhin und die letzte
Viertelstunde gehört ja immer den
Zuschauern und den Zuhörern und hören
wir doch mal Andreas Steinmann aus
Berlin guten Morgen ihre Frage bitte ja
einen schönen guten Morgen in die Runde
und zwar folgendes zu Russland
ich habe den Eindruck dass das noch Zeit
spielen muss kam in Wester viele Wahlen
gehabt und den eigentlich
Populisten und
entspannen sollte wieder prä werden
sollte wenn man sowieso alles klar
gemischt insofern braucht der neue Zeit
abzuwarten und dann noch ein Wort zu
China
es wäre politisch und Wirtschaft ja
selbst mit China die Beziehung
weitgehend abzubrechen dem in China
wollte zum Beispiel bei der
Autoindustrie es war die berühmte
deutsche Autoindustrie ganz in die Ecke
bringen wenn es nur wollten und die zwei
Fragen brauche nur noch Zeit zu führen
können wir uns wirtschaftlich das gar
nicht leisten mit China zu Verben danke
schön vielleicht kurz die russische ja
ich kann nur sagen sie haben völlig
recht genau das ist das Kalkül putin
wird auch zur Kenntnis nehmen dass bei
uns die AFD jetzt schon über 20% geraten
ist natürlich spekuliert er auch darauf
dass der Zusammenhalt im Westen
zerbröselt und gerade was Deutschland
angeht hat er da ja durchaus auch Grund
zu zu einer Wagen Hoffnung genau wir
haben über Trump gesprochen ich gebe ihn
völlig recht das ist dann Kalkül
ja zu China also es wird ja immer gern
verglichen ob hier den Ping dann seine
Lehren aus dem
aus Putins
Handeln zieht oder
muss erfolgen
man guckt in China natürlich schon sehr
genau hin aber China da gibt's halt
einen gravierenden Unterschied und den
haben sie dann ja auch angesprochen also
china hat noch ganz viele andere
Instrumente um Druck auf die
Weltgemeinschaft oder auch auf den
besten zu legen und das ist halt diese
Wirtschaftskraft also wenn wir auch
immer über Taiwan reden dann wird immer
von dem Szenario gesprochen wenn China
Taiwan angreift militärisch angreift es
gibt aber ganz viele Schritte davor auch
den Druck auf quasi die ganze Welt aus
ähm
auszuüben und ähm und zugunsten Chinas
zwei Drittel des Welthandels geht durch
die Gewässer rundum Taiwan da muss China
im Grunde nur mit Pablo Karten kommen
oder auch nur androhen und dann kann es
schon sein das ganz viele Länder nicht
zuletzt womöglich sogar auch Deutschland
dann auch schon klein beigeben wird also
china hat da ganz viele
Instrumente noch dazwischen die
erhebliche Konsequenzen haben werden und
das zweite ist natürlich schaut hier den
Ping nicht ganz genau an was in Moskau
passiert aber ich glaube es ist ganz
gefährlich dass wir daraus
Schlussfolgerung ziehen können und die
womöglich positiv sind dass sie dann
vielleicht weniger aggressiv ist das
kann nämlich genau das umgekehrte auch
passieren dass sie den Ping dann umso
mehr auf Kontrolle auf Repression auch
im eigenen System setzt damit ihm die
Kontrolle nicht entgleitet wie es bei
Putin zu tun vermag also insofern
bin ich dann mal ganz ganz vorsichtig
dazu sagen okay wenn das für Putin böse
ausgeht dann ist auch China zögerlich
ich bin mir da nicht so sicher
wenn wir mal rein hat Schneider guten
Tag Herr Schneider aus Düsseldorf
schönen guten Tag in die Runde also was
mir auffällt ist dass China eine
Ungeduld zeigt in
langfristigen Interessen der Chinesen
entgegen steht wohl wussten Gelassenheit
eine super macht sie so viel Vertrauen
in Überlegenheit und ihre Zivilisation
hat und ihre Zukunft zu sicher ist dass
Sie den richtigen Augenblicken kann
warum ist sind sie unter ungeduldig sie
könnten eigentlich nur abwarten
also das mag vielleicht so erscheinen
aber China ist unglaublich geduldig also
wenn man sich die ganzen Pläne anschaut
das macht mir sogar sorgen und zwar
umgekehrt weil wir dann doch immer sehr
verharrt sind immer in diesen vier
Jahres wahlzyklen zu denken und China
hat er nicht nur fünf Jahrespläne so aus
traditioneller kommunistischer also aus
der kommunistischen Tradition heraus
sondern die haben ja 10 Jahre 15 Jahre
bilden die Pläne die bis 2049 reichen
also dem hundertsten Jahrestag der
Volksrepublik also da habe ich den
Eindruck da ist China extrem geduldig
weil sie so langfristige Pläne schmieden
und die auch sehr sehr strategisch
angehen also da mache ich mir eher
insgesamt sorgen dass wir da nicht
Visionär genug denken dass wir nicht
auch ähnliche Pläne oder auch Vision für
Europa für oder für die ganze Welt dann
entwickeln weil die Chinesen die tun das
vielleicht meinte der Zuschauer aber
auch sowas wie die Absetzung jetzt die
chinesischen Außenministers etwas was ja
doch und ungewöhnlicher Schritt auch
selbst in China gleich hier den Ping hat
intern Feinde weil er ist ja auch er hat
dann genau mit dem Tabu gebrochen den
seine Vorgänger eigentlich vorgegeben
hat nicht gegen seine Vorgänger
vorzugehen das hat er getan und damit
hat er sich selbst auch für eine
geschaffen also das ist da
dass da nicht nur Harmonie herrscht in
Peking davon kann man ausgehen wir
wissen aber letztendlich auch nicht
genau was da die wirklichen Gründe für
die Absetzung ist wir können daraus nur
interpretieren dass ich hier den Pin
keineswegs so sicher auf dem Thron sitzt
wie es äh erst so zum Ausdruck bringen
möchte
kurze Frage warum
chinesische Politik so auf dem Besuch
von Frau pilotsi das ist doch das ist
doch so gewesen
keine
keine Waffen versprochen oder
irgendetwas was China betonen würde also
der Besuch in Taiwan das war fast ganz
genau rein in dieses politische
Machtspiel das langfristige Machtspiel
nämlich auch die Grenzen immer weiter zu
verschieben also immer mehr
den USA aber auch quasi den ganzen Rest
der Welt zu zeigen wir lassen uns von
niemanden beeindrucken sondern nicht
vielleicht von heute auf morgen schon
den Militärschlag aber Stück für Stück
äh die Grenzen zu verschieben und zu
sagen und den Einfluss auszuweiten also
auch den militärischen Einfluss also das
passt schon in diesem äh ich sag jetzt
mal nicht langfristigen aber
mittelfristigen Plan den China liegt
danke insofern und wir hören mal Frank
Knuth aus Berlin guten Tag danke
folgendes meine Frage ist kann China
dich Interesse haben das Russland gar
nicht so stark wird denn wir haben
nächstes Jahr Wahlen in Amerika
möglicherweise gewinnt Trump wieder
diese Wahlen Trump und Putin verstehen
sich sehr gut und dann ist jetzt heißt
Amerika gegen China und China gegen
Amerika bräuchten beide ja entweder ein
Partner oder jemanden der als Gegner
nicht so stark ist und deshalb wird es
doch gerade Schiene ins Gesicht passen
dass Russland zurzeit kränkelt und auch
gut in dieser schwaches weil die Gefahr
besteht dass er sich in einer
untereinandersetzung wenn das so kommt
nicht nur neutralfeld sondern
möglicherweise sogar aus mögliche
Interessen aus Seiten Amerikas schlägt
ja vielleicht erstmal her tischbauen
dazu ja ich glaube es ist so einfach zu
sagen in Trump und toten verstehen sich
ganz gut durch das ist glaube ich ein
Irrtum wenn man glaubt dass Trump wäre
der Freund von Puten glaube ich nicht
das würde nie mehr gerade auch nie im
Leben akzeptieren ähm so das ist so
würde ich nicht unterscheiden dass die
sich gut verstehen würden
außerdem wer weiß Trump gewinnt ich
glaube die Chancen sind weit weniger als
50 50
ja ein schwächeres Russland auf jeden
Fall aber das ist ja schon der Fall also
allein von der von der wirtschaftlichen
Dimension her aber auch nicht zu schwach
also wie gesagt china hat ein Interesse
das Putin im Amt bleibt weil sie zwei
Szenarien befürchten nämlich das eine
Szenario dass wenn Putin fällt womöglich
eine pro ein Pro westlicher Oligarch die
Macht übernimmt dann wäre China wirklich
China isoliert oder das andere Szenario
dass ein prigos oder irgendjemand aus
der wagnertruppe oder von ähnlichen
Kaliber in Moskau die haben Macht
übernimmt dann hätte ich China plötzlich
einen riesigen unberechten Nachbar das
will ich Ihnen auch nicht also schwächer
ja aber wie gesagt Putin soll auch nicht
fallen
ja und der hat Michler aus
niederseifersdorf guten Tag ihre Frage
bitte schönen guten Tag meine Frage ist
relativ kurz ich habe wie viele Bürger
bisschen Angst dass wir einen neuen
Kalten Krieg bekommen
momentan ist es so dass vor allen Dingen
im Medien auch
bestimmte Personen stark verteufelt
werden also jetzt sexy und der Putin und
neue Feindbilder aufgebaut werden die ja
durchaus es hat ja auch seinen Grund
aber hier geht's noch um viel mehr hier
geht's einfach darum dass
global obwohl
Machtverteilung gestritten wird und das
macht dann Angst verlassen Kalten Krieg
kann ja auch mal ein heißer Krieg werden
und diese Aufrüstung die jetzt uns
bevorsteht die hat mit
Wohlstandsverlusten zu tun es wird immer
wieder Störung geben deswegen meine
Frage sieht irgendjemand in der Runde
die Möglichkeit dass man
zwischen den Systemen wieder mehr
Vertrauen herstellt das ist wie unter
Menschen wenn man sich vertraut dann
dann sind Gewaltmittel weit weniger
attraktiv und man kommt zu besseren
Verhältnissen die weniger
konfliktträchtig sind ich erinnere daran
es gab ja in Europa mal diesen Helsing
die Prozess wo man vereinbart hatte sich
nicht in die inneren Angelegenheiten
anderer Länder zu sehr einzumischen
könnte man dort wieder hinkommen wer
könnte da eine Rolle spielen auch wenn
der Ukraine Krieg irgendwann mal zu Ende
ist das ist ja jetzt erstmal nur
zwischen der tappe aber dass man weiter
denkt wie kommen wir zu mehr vertrauen
dass mir um Gottes Willen an neuen
Kalten Krieg verhindern der allen massiv
Schaden wird und
bisschen weg auf von von dieser
Verteufelung einzelner Personen das ist
billige Propaganda System ja also mehr
vertrauen wie kann das gehen ja also ich
muss sagen ich alle ihre Sorge ich finde
das manchmal auch sehr beängstigend ich
finde auch dass wir als Journalisten
daran arbeiten müssen nicht diese
Feindbilder unkritisch zu replizieren
aber es gibt eben bestimmte Fakten die
man nicht ausblenden kann und klar an
putinen oder an anderen Diktaturen auf
dieser Welt kann man sich leider nur die
Zähne ausbeißen aber das ist jetzt
vielleicht nicht das richtige Forum aber
ich glaube es geht so in diese Debatte
auch rein also was bringen eben
Sanktionen tragen die dazu bei dass die
Diktaturen fallen oder nicht welche sind
geblieben trotz Sanktionen also wir
können alles mögliche ausprobieren und
wir tun es auch und ich glaube es ist
ganz wichtig dass das immer weiter tun
aber bestimmte Szenarien müssen wir
wahrscheinlich durchstehen aber das
bedeutet eben umso wichtiger ist es dass
man wegen die EU auch zusammenhalten ist
bestimmte Sachen gibt so Werte die noch
weiter stehen aber wie gesagt wir können
uns die Leute nicht aussuchen wir müssen
Minimum an Umgang haben weil wir alle
voneinander abhängen und deswegen glaube
ich auch dass bestimmte verteufelungen
eben nicht weiterhelfen das ist wäre
glaube ich wichtig dass man immer wieder
noch mal überlegt kann ich zur Sachebene
zurückkommen kann ich
wirtschaftsbeziehung weiter ausbauen
kann ich noch mal kritische
Menschenrechtsfragen ansprechen auch
wenn es vielleicht gerade nicht das
richtige Forum ist aber dranbleiben also
komplett alles dicht machen und nur auf
den Feind einschießen glaube ich ist
nicht hilfreich okay kleine Gegenrede
erst mal sollten wir im Augenblick keine
Angst vor einem kalten Krieg haben wir
haben einen verdammt heißen Krieg mitten
in Europa zweite Gegenrede die Sache mit
dem Vertrauen haben wir in Deutschland
vor allem in Berlin 22 Jahre lang
wirklich nachhaltig versucht egal was
Putin macht oder auch in der
völkerrechtspart die kriminiert einen
Krieg anzettelte haben wir immer wieder
versucht dieses von ihnen ja gewünschte
Vertrauen aufzubringen und zu hoffen
dass wir über
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen irgendwie den
Laden stabilisiert kriegen das Ergebnis
kennen sie da bin ich ziemlich nah Oskar
Fischer hat gerade noch mal im intervie
ganz klar gesagt Russland wird auf
absehbar lange Zeit ein gefährlicher
Gegner bleiben und wir müssen die
Ukraine in die NATO aufnehmen die
einzige Chance auf vertrauensvolle
Beziehungen zu moskau ist nach einer
krachenden Niederlage und einem Reset in
Russland einem Abschied der russischen
Bevölkerung und Politik von imperialen
aggressiven und kolonialen Ideen die
ganz tief verwurzelt sind wir können
jetzt lange noch reden
dass man sich seine Partner nicht
aussuchen kann ja genau aber im
Augenblick ist meine Devise nicht auf
Vertrauen zu hoffen einem Mann gegenüber
der 22 Jahre chronisch permanent bei
jedem Punkt lügt und jeden Vertrag
bricht oder darauf zu hoffen dass wir
die Ukraine ermächtigen diesen
militärischen Konflikte möglichst gut zu
beenden und dann darauf hoffen dass
irgendwann den Russland auch die netten
Russen die sich demok ratie ja wünschen
um jeden Preis das ist ja nicht so dass
alle potenzfans sind im Gegenteil dass
die eine Chance kriegen wieder in einem
zivilisierten demokratischen Land zu
leben aber davor muss eine letzte
Zuschauerfrage würden wir noch schaffen
wenn wir uns jetzt beeilen Ulrich Platz
Frankfurt
klar unterscheiden zwischen den
Interessen der jeweiligen
Regimes und denen der Nationen die sind
ja auch sind ja mal gar nicht identisch
also Regimes brauchen äußere Feinde um
an der Macht zu bleiben und das ist der
Hauptinteresse wenn in China die
internen Probleme zunehmenden dann
würden die Taiwan überfallen aber aus
dem Grund um selber ihre Regie zu
stabilisieren und bei Putin kann man
doch klar sehen der hat in den 22 Jahren
nur zwei drei Jahre ohne Kriege gehabt
und die Kriege haben immer wieder seine
Popularität gesteigert und haben ihn an
der Macht gehalten
werden
genau da muss man genauer hingucken also
wenn man gerade darüber redet gucken und
nicht nur auf Nationen ja definitiv und
ich meine die Menschen spielen natürlich
auch eine Rolle also aus China bezogen
ich glaube die in die Chinesen leiden ja
selbst unter dieser Politik für
unterschiedlichen pingen unter wieder
mehr verschlossenen Repression und so
weiter und sie wünschen sich ja nichts
sinnlicher als dass sich die Welt wieder
öffnet also darauf auch zu setzen die
Kontakte die menschlichen die
wirtschaftlichen Kontakt da auch
weiterhin zu pflegen natürlich mit die
fliegen muss leider unser Schlusswort
sein weil wir sind am Ende der Sendezeit
herzlichen Dank Ihnen für die Diskussion
Ihnen
noch einen schönen Sonntag tschüss
[Musik]